[Music]
if you're thinking of a wild mushroom
you're probably thinking of death and
poisoning and vomiting
but now that i'm a mushroom hunter i
think wonder opportunity delicacy
potential beauty every corner in the
forest has a new surprise
in the mycological world behind it my
name is ari rocklin miller and i'm jenna
antonino dimari and we are microphiles
aka mushroom lovers
[Music]
in the united states alone there are at
least 40 or 50 gourmet edible wild
mushrooms
and those run the gamut from the
chanterelle with a powerful apricot
aroma to the black trumpet with an
earthy fig like flavor to the hen of the
woods which looks like a hen roosting at
the base of an oak tree in the fall
there's an unbelievable diversity
[Music]
when i was a little kid i would just
pile up every mushroom i could find in
the woods around my house that was the
beginning of the journey
i do have dreams about wild mushroom and
then i sort of wake up and first thing i
want to do the next morning is get out
for mushrooms
[Music]
often i'm moving fast
looking for
brightly colored mushrooms other times
i'm really getting down on my hands and
knees crawling around the moss at the
base of a beech tree looking for a black
trumpet
ari can become extremely enthusiastic
about hunting for mushrooms and there
have been times in the past where he'll
be out for hours and hours and hours at
a time but won't come back with anything
finding them does take time
but then every now and then all of a
sudden you see one
and that is the most powerful reverie
unbelievable rush every time
we use our knife and our mushroom brush
and fill up our basket we don't over
harvest mushrooms there isn't a monetary
incentive
we do want to leave some in the ground
to spread their spores and to reproduce
the hunt is intrinsically satisfying
it's an epic treasure hunt it reconnects
me to a childhood sense of wonder
on a good day
we can bring home many pounds of wild
mushrooms
[Music]
when we bring our mushrooms back it's
always such a joy to look through our
find from the day
and cook them up that evening
[Music]
we don't resell the mushrooms that we
find in the forest we instead enjoy them
ourselves we pick just enough
to share with our family and friends
[Music]
mushrooms have taught me that even in
the tiniest things there's so much
potential that there are whole worlds
that we ignore
that contain so much
flavor beauty mystery wonder
[Music]
you